assalamu alaikum greetings of peace how
you guys doing welcome to the dean show
listen i'm going to go through some very
important points really quickly i need
you guys to really focus
i want to cover them fast and i'll give
some details to it
and why am i doing this is to point out
the clear hypocrisy
double standards with many of the
islamophobes and much of the media
and also with a old friend of ours we
did a program
for clearing up much of the lies and and
the great blunders that
our friend louder crowder had done but
we left the door open we delivered this
message with peace
academically refuted much of the lies
that he had
presented to the people misled the
people and we had such a positive
feedback because people don't like being
lied to people want
like he says kind of honesty that
our generation of americans
want thirst for and consume this is a
generation
that is thirsting for truth so now we're
gonna go ahead and react
he did up someone asked me to respond to
what he said regarding the terrorist
attack and we commend him
and we'll address that also towards the
end for coming out and having some
empathy so let's watch this
and then we'll go over those eight
points that i'm talking about he says
that he is not a christian
and he identifies as an eco-fascist now
louder does mention that he
identifies with being an eco-fascist
this could be similar with someone
identifying being a republican
a democrat a political movement
so louder crowder he said that this
terrorist wasn't wasn't a christian
do i believe he was a christian no i
don't believe he was representing
christianity a true christian
following the way of jesus peace be upon
him no way i don't think there's any
muslim out there very sensitive
muslims are very sensitive not to hurt
the christians feelings
and to to to make this unity to work
together we can agree to disagree on on
many things but we should be working to
make this earth that we live on muslims
ain't going nowhere christians ain't
going anywhere
we need to work together as
residents on this earth to make the
earth a better place for all of us now
there are eight points that i want to
mention loudren crowder said he wasn't a
christian okay
but i want to show the clear hypocrisy
and double standards
and a disclaimer never is it my
intention nor through this do i want to
hurt any christians
or to misrepresent christianity or to
hurt anybody's feelings this is not the
idea here
but again i want you as a christian a
just a person in humanity an
intellectual academic
to show that with these eight points
that i bring up
would the media be able to link him to
christianity
and call him a christian and then do
what they do with islam because as soon
as someone walks by a muslim
has lunch with a muslim anyhow which way
connected to islam
any which way how they will put islam on
the witness stand
you know how the story goes radical
islam muslim terror
risk you see it all the time would they
be able to do the same thing with this
man
but obviously you don't see christian
terrorists radical christianity
nor should they we don't want them to do
that but keep it fair balance and you
decide would they be able to manipulate
the situation
use these these evidences as these
proofs as evidence
to do something malicious like that
let's look at it number one
he went according to this manifesto
attributed to him
he went to seek blessings with this
group called the templar knights which
they are trying to revive
some say that they're like a secret
sauce society out there
and andrew brevlick who also was a
he was a christian and he went again not
representing christianity true
christianity or the true jesus of t
jesus we make that clear he went and
sought his blessings he's supposed to be
his night this templar knight also
so he was going to seek blessings from
this group the templar knights that
still allegedly
out there why is he doing that imagine
real quickly
what would happen if someone went to
seek blessings from al-qaeda or desh or
this isis what would happen why are you
seeking blessings from them for what
so are you non-muslim or you're or
you're muslim if you're doing that
so you're going to seek blessings from
the templar knights are you a christian
not a christian why are you seeking
their blessings
think about that i'll let you decide at
the end let's move let's move on
number two the dates on his gun there
were specific dates you had
also some extreme elements who
considered
who call themselves christian they did
some terrorist acts
and he had those dates of those attacks
on there and dates
to crusader events now you know the
crusaders they wreaked havoc in the land
you know the the pope who let them out
these people absolve them of their sins
gave a free pass pretty much told them
if they go out and they let
criminals out rapists out to go out and
that's what they did they wrecked havoc
and they terrorized
so they're trying to re bring
this crusade so he has those crusader
dates
on his weapon now you tell me why are
they there
he's christian not christian what's
specifically his agenda
it's up to you to decide at the end i'm
just bringing these important points to
you he also had a crusader song from the
techniques now the techniques
are this extreme element of from a
nationality called the serbs
now we don't try to put down serbs or
croatians or anybody because
that's a nationality and in every
nationality you have extreme elements so
we don't
just like bash the whole ethnic group
the ethnicity but you had techniques
these were people who were out there
they committed one of the not the
greatest genocide
genocide after world war ii and this
song was
made for karadzic these people like
karadzic lodges specifically here this
war criminal
he was convicted of war crimes they had
rape camps
death camps they killed innocent men
women and children
this was also under
it was hidden nobody called them
christian terrorists
but they were hiding behind christianity
you had priests blessing their guns and
weapons
and this song was a motivating song for
this crusader these
techniques who were hiding behind
christianity i don't call them true
christians
and they went and committed these these
atrocities this terrorism
the greek orthodox church described him
as quote
one of the most prominent sons of our
lord jesus christ working for peace
now he thanked god on many occasions so
what is he is he
he's he's he's thanking god so what
religion is he on
thank god goodbye god bless you all now
imagine if a muslim
he said alhamdulillah what would they do
with that what would the media the
islamophobes
what would they do with that again what
would i'm leaving that up to you what
has been done already
again islam is vilified put on the stand
and the list goes on of all the evil
evil malicious things that are done we
use crusader
terrorist crusader lingo
such as calling the muslims saracens
he also encouraged in one part he said
he said death is certain you may die in
the service
to some grand crusade or pass away in a
hospice
so look again what would happen if
someone was
invited you might you can die in the
grand service of a grand
and they use they throw jihad out there
they say in a grand jihad or in a
hospice
so he'd be calling to a jihad right and
jihadis
simply means to struggle and to strive
against evil against oppression against
yourself your desires and the list goes
on we're not covering that here
but then what if this was used
and now this word was thrown in the
opposite thing happened
the same way here he's inviting to a
grand crusade
using lingo and calling muslims with
crusader terms
could they take this and manipulate it
and say he was a christian and this is
radical christianity like they do with
islam
clear double standards and hypocrisy is
what we're pointing out
he has a whole page dedicated where it
says two christians
now i believe i first thought these were
his words but i think because they're in
quotations
he's quoting someone and it says the
people worthy of glory the people
blessed by god
and this is by a another
crusader pope a terrorist who went
terrorizing people
he's trying to invoke a crusade so
imagine someone trying to invoke what
they islamophobes call like these
jihadis they're coming to get us
and all the other things that they
perpetuate to make you scared of muslims
to create this f manufactured hate and
fear
when statistically it is factual
the data shows that muslims
commit the least acts of terrorism this
is statistical or factual you can check
it up
and now the final point he's he's
because he's doing a question and answer
back and forth and he asks himself are
you christian
it's a simple and it's a simple quote
are you a christian someone says are you
muslim
if you're if you're not muslim i'm not
muslim but then how does he respond he
says
that that's complicated i'll let you
know when i figure it out now imagine on
the other side
if that was and all of these i want you
to go and compare
if this was a muslim and same thing back
and forth what kind of
games they would be you know analyzing
it all of these points they would be
analyzing and they'd have talk shows and
back and forth and crossfires on this
and it would be 24
7 media and they would be trying to
perpetuate this and
and fueling more of the hate in the
division so he mentions giving people
the kind of honesty that this generation
they want and thirst for
so you should be honest when it comes to
talking about muslims and islam honest
academic not making up these lies like
we called you out for last time
now that was in the past you can make it
right for that and for the future
we you can go back and how we address
that and you can go ahead
and instead of the copy and paste out of
context what you are doing
you can call an academic a scholar of
islam
someone who's in this area of expertise
and come and let's talk
and let's work together or would you
continue
to espouse hate misinformation and lies
about islam and muslims you showed like
you had some empathy
for those 49 innocent human beings that
had died in a house of worship a house
of god
and you were you were coming off like
you're genuine and sincere and only god
knows what's in your heart
and my heart just breaks for the
families the people affected
in christchurch new zealand in this
just deplorable terrorist
mass murder attack sending prayers you
said and
it breaks your heart as you said but i'm
asking you but then the next day
you go and bring on one of the biggest
number one islamophobes in the world
whose only mission is fueling people
like this terrorists who did that people
who listen to people like that
they can only develop hate if someone
comes out
and all you can learn from this is to
hate islam and muslims
what good are they contributing to
making peace and understanding
and giving proper education when they're
you're giving them a platform
to promote lies misunderstanding and
hate and that's what you did
and that's ingenuous and insincere so
you went from being sincere
and then you went what seemed to be
sincere
saying your heart was broke and you're
making these these saying these
beautiful nice things and then
where did you go on from there you bring
on the biggest islamophobe
one of the top islamophobes haters out
there
so wrapping it up one final thing you
had mentioned we should not be
a people dividing the country for clicks
dividing the country
for clicks
why don't we stick with that if you
truly want
peace and understanding work towards it
the muslims are there
so you can espouse these bigoted
hateful this hate rhetoric towards
muslim towards islam and muslims
these lies that you perpetuate these
insults
towards prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him
or you can go ahead and try to work
towards a common good like you were
saying
and i address my christian
colleagues friends i have a lot of them
christian friends out there
to call out people like this these are
not the best of you
these are not the best of you who are
hating to compound the problem
call them out be if they be in your
churches i've shown you guys what
happens when someone
goes and even makes a joke about being
a part of this group isis i've showed
you what happens there
yeah i assist in
but what about these people who are
trying to bring these ideas
who are trying to incite this hate in
the churches the politicians
you need to call them out you cannot let
this hate rhetoric that leads
islamophobia kills
it leads to what happened of tragedy
of evil in new zealand it leads to that
don't let it come to that
jews and christians muslims
we are all here on this earth nobody's
going anywhere
so we need to work together in peace and
harmony but the constant islamophobia
the manufactured hate fear the quarter
of a million that's spent
traumatizing people that's what you're
doing perpetuating lies
misinformation give the muslims a shot
to get out there represent themselves
go ahead and ask them the tough
questions and let the people decide
let the people decide and i'm letting
you decide now at the end
could they because that's what we
started with i asked you i'm gonna i'm
gonna bring up some
some points from the manifesto
attributed to this terrorist
that killed 49 innocent human beings
muslims
in a house of worship a house of god
could the media as they do always with
islam and muslims
could they from what i just mentioned
can they associate and say no no he was
a christian
practicing christianity and then call
christianity radical christianity
a christian terrorist which nobody's
doing and i'm not saying that they
should
but they should be fair and balanced
because you cannot
based on one individual or a group of
individuals
malign a whole faith a whole way of life
like islam or christianity let's keep it
fair and balance pointing out the
double standards and hypocrisy here on
the deviant show
our door is always open to mr crowd and
others with an invitation of peace
because we're people of peace and we end
with the greeting of jesus shalom
lake peace assalamu alaikum peace be
with you